where we left off in the last video
Alexander dies in 323 BCE at the young
age of 32 and even though he conquered
all of this territory it was a very
short-lived Empire and what happens next
is a period known as the Wars of the
diadochi
and let me write down this word do dokey
so diadochi translates into successors
and these are the various leaders and
mainly generals of Alexander who then
fought for control of the Empire and
it's a very bloody period a lot of
different deed okie going after each
other or after each other's families and
what eventually happens over the next
few decades is alexander's empire the
empire that he establishes gets split up
into a few major empires now what you
see on this map here you see most of
Persia and the Anatolian Peninsula right
over here really the the bulk of the old
a committed Persian Empire it gets under
control of Seleucus and he establishes
the Seleucid dynasty the Seleucid Empire
let me write this down right here this
is Seleucid so the Seleucid Empire Egypt
right over here this gets taken control
of another general of Alexander Ptolemy
and he establishes the Ptolemaic Empire
and the Ptolemaic dynasty Dali make and
then Macedon ends up under control once
again of another diadochi
remember the dido key or the successors
all of these all of these characters
right over here these are three of the
various Dido key three of the more
successful Dido key right over here but
what the the the Macedonian components
of Alexander's Empire for the most part
end up under the control of Antigonus
--is dynasty which ends up being called
the Antigone dynasty and
Teagan it and this at any as you can see
it's not all of the Empire Alexander
established what we have in red here
these are independent states that did
not get subsumed into the Seleucid the
Ptolemaic or the Antigone empires
and they you know you can imagine over
the next several hundred years they're
going back and forth there's an ebb and
flow of control of these various empires
but these are the three most significant
especially the Ptolemaic and the
Seleucid now what this establishes is
what a lot of historians refer to as a
new period of especially this part of
the world we when we go from shortly
before the Persian invasions of Greece
all the way to Alexander great we refer
to that as classical Greece but now
we're going from classical Greece
classical Greece with the death of
Alexander in the beginning of the Wars
of the do-deca foot for control this
sets up a new period often referred to
by historians and as Hellenistic
Hellenistic Hellenistic period and the
Hellenistic period is referring to the
fact that all of this territory that was
conquered by Alexander the Great and
later gets split after the Wars of the
Deki between these DoD establishing
these various empires they had huge
influence of Greek culture you had
ruling dynasties that were essentially
Greek whether you're in Ptolemaic Egypt
Seleucid Persia or Antigone Macedonia
obviously the Macedonians were already a
very strong Greek culture and it it's
it's a time where you have this the
spread of the culture you have kind of a
bit of fulfillment of Alexander the
Great's goal of creating this very this
mash up so to speak of the various
cultures of the region the Greco and the
Persian and the Egyptian cultures now
the Hellenistic period starts to end as
each of these various empires get
overthrown the Seleucid Empire in the
3rd century BCE it gets more and more
overtaken by the Parthian Empire Parthia
starts as a as a trap region of the
Seleucid Empire but it eventually takes
control over much of Persia so this is
the Parthian sorry the Parthian Parthian
Parthian Empire right over here and the
last vestiges of the seleucid empire are
eventually defeated by the Roman legions
and you'll see this is a common trend
here because at the time of Alexander on
the Italian peninsula you start having a
city-state that's becoming more and more
powerful and more and more of an empire
and as we will see it starts to subsume
a lot of the regions we talked about
Ptolemaic Egypt
it gets overthrown by the Roman Empire
and 30 BCE and the an ticketed dynasty
gets overthrown by the Roman Empire
they're actually the first to get
overthrown by the Roman Empire in 168 BC
so this period this Hellenistic period
the take away it's a it's a period you
know I'm talking about hundreds of years
in a matter of five or six minutes but
this is this is a period where you had
significant Greek influence over a very
large period or a very large area of
land and it eventually ends with a lot
of the western portions falling under
Roman control and the eastern portions
especially Persia falling under Parthian
control